[Musique]
si nous avons des informations c'est
pour porter ça au public parce que
papa
il est là
nous profitons un peu de cette tribune
pour demander aux autorités sénégalaises
de le libérer encore une fois pape
alignant n'a rien à faire en prison et
sa place est dans les relations la
liberté de la presse dans un pays comme
le Sénégal qui jadis était un fleuron de
la presse et en danger et menacé
aujourd'hui c'est la presse Thomas c'est
un autre acteur qui n'est pas
journaliste nous sommes tous menacés
parce que aujourd'hui dès que vous dites
il ne faut pas détourner l'argent des
Sénégalais vous êtes une cible dès que
vous prenez votre caméra vous montrer ce
que eux ne veulent pas que les
Sénégalais voient vous êtes menacés
[Musique]
il n'a pas été arrêté dans la rue
en plein trafic de drogue ou bien parce
qu'il a tué quelqu'un ou bien parce
qu'il a escroqué quelqu'un non c'est
dans l'exercice de ces fonctions et
parce que c'est dans l'existence de ces
fonctions que la corporation est obligée
à l'obligation de défendre papa
c'est pour ça que nous sommes sur le
terrain et nous continuerons à la
défendre quoi qu'il advienne
les présidents abandonné
[Musique]